for more than 30 years the simpsons has
skewered
every major player in the pop culture
landscape including marvel
while some of these superhero jokes are
obvious
others aren't quite as easy to spot here
are some marvel references
in the simpsons that you might have
missed
one of the earliest and best crusading
lisa episodes of the simpsons is
lisa versus malibu stacy in this classic
episode the sensitive
political and staunchly feminist middle
simpson child
strikes back against the manufacturers
of a barbie-like doll called
malibu stacy in the past lisa was a huge
malibu stacey fan
and collector but she becomes deeply
offended by a new talking version of the
doll
it has a voice chip that delivers an
assortment of stereotypical phrases such
as let's make cookies for the boys and
don't ask me i'm just a girl malibu
stacy
also utters this line which further
pushes
lisa to the edge
at this point lisa rants to the other
girls about her issues with the doll
a confused classmate admits there's
something wrong with her malibu stacy
my spidey sense is tingling anybody call
for a web slinger
this of course is one of the phrases
used by the marvel comics character
spider-man it's also a much more obscure
reference to an early
90s activist group called the barbie
liberation
organization this group secretly
replaced the voice chips of mattel's
teen talk barbie which said things like
math class is tough in favor of sayings
from talking gi joe action figures like
eat lead cobra and plenty of other
battle ready expressions
the simpsons has always been loaded with
sight gags that only pop onto the screen
for a second or two
making plenty of these jokes easy to
miss and whenever the simpsons family
heads to a movie
viewers should keep a sharp eye on the
marquee outside the theater because
there are likely to be a few clever
takes on popular film
titles of course marvel has had more
than a few of its comic book characters
and
movie titles twisted by the writers of
the simpsons for instance
in the 2004 episode the zeth who came to
dinner there's a brief shot of the
theater's marquee
offering such error-specific fake films
as the fashion of the christ
eating nemo and the unwatchable hulk
the last one is a sly reference to the
2003 hulk film
the first appearance of the angry green
guy on the big screen which was far from
a hit with the critics
similarly in a 2018 episode the simpsons
go to see a film
at the capital city googleplex along
with titles like
transformers fatigue and the lego get
out movie there's a film called
marvel letters to the editor a dig at
how the company has used
seemingly everything from its comics
canon as movie fodder
after watching a marvel film the
simpsons stick around for the credits
which mentioned that mark ruffalo who
plays the hulk has an
anger coach and that stan lee was
created by
stan lee's parents however as we all
know
marvel movies are never really over when
the credits start to roll and this
animated parody is no exception the
simpsons make fun of the mcu's love of
mid
credit and post credit sequences that
reveal huge plot twists and
wet audience appetites by setting up
future movies
marvel letters to the editor has a
mid-credit scene that brings a beloved
character back from the dead
in this case it's peter parker's uncle
ben only now
he's unspeakably evil and revealed as
the film's villain after that
there's yet another sequence which sets
things up for an avengers like movie
featuring
the assemblers who the hell are you i'm
assembling a team of the best team
assemblers in the world
and i want you to help me put together
that team
plenty of marvel movies have been origin
stories such as the 2002 spider-man
which tells how peter parker became a
web-slinging wall-crawling superhero
and many elements of this sam raimi film
are gently parodied in simple simpson a
2004 episode which serves as the origin
story for homer's short-lived superhero
identity
pie man it all starts at the county fair
where lisa enters a table setting
contest
unfortunately the judge an obnoxious
rich texan thinks her project
stinks like the south end of a
northbound mule
and goes about humiliating her for his
own entertainment when homer sees his
daughter being mocked by the judge he
becomes
angry to the point of violence however
remembering that
chief wiggum told him he'd go to jail if
he committed another felony assault
homer takes another path
to vengeance he steals items from
various fare booths and fashions them
into a crude superhero outfit
announcing himself as pie man and
avengers lisa by throwing a pie
in the rich texan's face before homer
can write
any other wrongs he needs a proper pie
costume
the episode then launches into a montage
of homer drawing up ideas for his pie
man look then dutifully sewing one
together that doesn't look quite as good
as what he'd probably
imagined the whole thing is reminiscent
of peter parker creating his own
less than stellar first outfit in
spider-man this simpsons episode has
another big reference to the film with
an upside down kiss
between pie man and marge
i'm looking up your nose but i feel like
i'm staring into your soul
mona lisa from 2006 is a truly classic
episode of the simpsons in that it gives
viewers its signature mix
of references to highbrow interests and
accessible pop culture renowned authors
jonathan franzen
michael chaban tom wolf and gore vidal
make voice cameos while there's also an
extended sequence
involving a side character from the
spider-verse
specifically as he was presented in the
first trilogy of spider-man movies
during the episode lisa discovers that
mo the bartender is a dark
sad everyman poet in the vein of charles
bukowski
and she sends his work to the literary
journal american poetry perspectives and
who happens to be the magazine's editor
it's none other than jay jonah jameson
who's apparently
moved on from his job at the helm of the
daily bugle i need photos photos of
spider-man this is a poetry journal
okay then poems about spider-man jameson
is voiced by academy award-winning
character actor
jk simmons who portrayed him in the toby
maguire spider-man movies as well as
spider-man
far from home references to comic books
and its surrounding culture have been
part of the simpsons for decades
even back when collecting comics was a
relatively niche pastime bart simpson
and milhouse regularly visit
springfield's comic source the android's
dungeon
and baseball card shop run by the
usually arrogant and dismissive
comic book guy however in the episode
but where am i cheating bart
two of springfield's young residents
wind up at the store not for comic books
but for a romantic refuge
the travel starts when neighborhood
bully jimbo forces bart to escort his
girlfriend shauna to places he doesn't
want to go and the true develop
romantic feelings for each other after
they're caught kissing at the public
pool
bart and shauna hide from jimbo and his
bully friends at the androids dungeon
comic book guy greets them with words
that would make any thor fan
feel at ease think of this as your
personal asgard and i the all-seeing
heimdall
guardian of the gate that's three
references to norse mythology in one
sentence but since
this is comic book guy it's safe to
assume that he's referring to the norse
mythology inspired world of marvel's
thor
but wait there's one more marvel
reference in this scene
after shauna makes fun of comic book
guy's weight he alerts jimbo and the
bullies where she's hiding shauna then
starts a flame war with him
and he drops a classic marvel lion oh
flame on even casual fans will recognize
flame on as the catchphrase of the human
torch from
the fantastic four in bart the bad guy
but becomes the most powerful person in
springfield after he watches an advanced
copy of the superhero saga vindicators
crystal war
ii resurgence he was able to view it on
a laptop that he lifted from a drunk
passed out star of the film
now bart can get anything he wants by
threatening to reveal spoilers for the
highly anticipated blockbuster
clearly the film is a send up of
avengers infinity war
and end game complete with a powerful
space titan
and emotional cliffhanger the episode
starts with just about everyone in
springfield watching the first
crystal war movie in the film's final
climactic scene the thanos-like
chinos comes into possession of the
doomsday app
which he used to turn the protagonists
into crystals that shatter
like infinity war the crystal war films
are overloaded with superheroes most of
which have easily identifiable marvel
counterparts
for instance there's the simpsons
version of iron man
magnesium man who is always ready with a
witty bit of dialogue another main
character in the episode is
airshot he's clearly based on hawkeye
except
instead of being an expert archer he's
mastered the pump
action air gun
[Music]
yes air shot pump that air gun five
pumps think of the pressure the episode
is packed with visual references to
recent marvel movies but it also throws
in
a musical nod to one of their films from
the previous decade
during one scene we hear the song people
get up and drive your funky soul
while bart walks down the hall of his
school this is the same
james brown tune that accompanies peter
parker's infamous
struck down the street in 2007
spider-man 3.
in elementary school musical an episode
from 2010
krusty the clown achieves the
unthinkable he wins the nobel peace
prize
however it's all just the ruse to get
him onto a plane which lands at the
hague
where krusty is arrested and is set to
be tried by the international court of
justice
he'll be released only if someone can
find proof that krusty has contributed
significantly to culture in any way
homer and bart scrambled to locate some
kind of evidence of krusty's artistic
importance
after scouring the internet they find a
my tube clip of the pbs educational show
the electric company the simpsons
version of the show features a character
who seems to be inspired by easyreader
who was portrayed on the real electric
company
by a young morgan freeman predictably
krusty's appearance on the show goes
completely
haywire gotta hide me i slept with the
lighting director's wife and
[Music]
this is a deep marvel cut as a low
budget version of spider-man really did
appear on the electric
company in the 70s the 2017
episode springfield splendor alludes to
the title of the classic
indie comic american splendor but on the
whole the episode satirizes
all kinds of comic books and other
properties they've spawned in recent
years
after lisa writes a confessional
autobiographical novel called
sad girl as art therapy comic book guy
publishes it without her permission
you published my private art therapy as
a comic book
um actually it's a graphic novel the
distinctions are threefold
shut up however the graphic novel
becomes a hit and lisa is invited to be
on a panel at comic-con like real-life
pop culture conventions attendees dress
as their favorite comic book and movie
characters
there's a brief shot of a fan wearing a
cheap ramshackle tree costume
clearly he's attempting to cosplay as
groot from guardians of the galaxy
also it looks like stan lee is in the
background later in the episode
lisa's sad girl gets turned into a
musical which is ostensibly a send-up of
the graphic novel
to broadway success of alison bechdel's
fun home
also the score for the sad girl live
experience is the same score
from the ill-fated broadway musical
spider-man
turn off the dark the late stan lee was
basically synonymous with marvel comics
he was a lifelong cheerleader for the
company where he helped invent
dozens of legendary characters it was
only fitting that he turned in an
extended cameo in a simpsons episode
that finds bart becoming a major player
in the comics business
after bart visits the androids dungeon
to get comic book guy's opinion on a
character he created
lee offers up his own expert critique
when bart returns to the store later he
notices that lee is still hanging around
coming for guy posits that lee's mind is
no longer in mint condition which is
illustrated when he's trying to convince
a customer that an action figure of the
thing
can fit into a much smaller batmobile
later in the episode
homer becomes enraged after falling into
an inflatable pool
filled with green paint and is mistaken
for the hulk when lee sees this
happening he can't help but get involved
i'm the hulk
oh please you couldn't even change into
bill bixby
twelve seasons later a vision of lee
tries to convince comic book guy to
pursue the girl he loves when he asks
for help
lee declines and says i can only watch i
cannot interfere
that's a subtle nod to a bit of dialogue
spoken by the watchers the marvel
characters seen in guardians of the
galaxy
and fantastic four however when comic
book guy starts to lose his nerve the
vision of lee returns to lend a helping
hand
come on nude nick ask her out you're
interfering hey i'm 90 years old i can
do what i want
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the simpsons are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one